Comicon takes places you know mostly
inside a huge convention hall but just
in case you plan on spending any time
outdoors this week here's Andy Richter
with the weather report and he takes
away
thanks Conan we've got clear skies and
temps in the high 70s throughout San
Diego and it's cooling down to the low
70s out by the bay now let's check out
the forecast for middle-earth we're
looking at a nice cool 53 in the shower
urn the Shire and over here at Mordor
highs all the way up to 11 T 1 and be on
the lookout for that giant flaming
eyeball which has been lighting up the
night sky recently I don't know what it
is but it sure is pretty
meanwhile over in Narnia looking at some
pretty heavy-handed Christian metaphors
throughout the entire region
the desert planet boom oh that drought
shows no chance of letting up bad let's
check out the weather in Westeros bundle
up everybody because winter is coming as
well as hordes of the undead sweeping
down from the north now let's take a
look at the five thousand year forecast
for Westeros snow snow
[Laughter]
[Music]
very nice handy great jobs right back
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]